Australia is a pretty big place and one
that was entirely colonized by one
country the United Kingdom Britain
wasn't the first European country to
discover Australia that was the
Netherlands and in spite of the fact
that all of these nations had interests
nearby there was no desperate Scramble
for this mass of land and no other
European State ever settled it which
raises the question why why wasn't there
a Scramble for Australia and why was it
just left for Britain so the first
Europeans to discover Australia were the
Dutch in 1606 who promptly named it New
Holland after Holland back home over the
following Century Australia was visited
by Sailors from many countries who map
most of its Coast it wasn't long before
the Dutch East India Company considered
the idea of colonizing New Holland but
in the end it decided against the
Venture the reason was that there were
no known resources to exploit and there
weren't very many indigenous people to
do it for them eventually in the latter
half of the 18th century the British
mapped out the Eastern Coastline of
Australia and found several places of
interest and two decades later the
British government agreed to colonize
the area of Botany Bay here there were
three reasons that Britain said yes to
this the first was that the people they
were sending were convicts and so it
didn't really matter if things didn't
work out previously Britain had sent
convicts to North America but due to an
ongoing event of Freedom that was no
longer possible the second reason was
that Britain wasn't looking for
resources to sell or people to tax
Australia sat in a convenient place for
raiding French Spanish and especially
Dutch shipping which would help Britain
in any future Wars and mostly they were
just looking to get rid of convicts and
the third reason was that the British
believed that it would be easy because
no other major Powers were trying and
there were barely any natives there to
resist the British landed in 1788
founding the settlement of Sydney town
in what's now New South Wales so after
this why didn't any other European power
try to keep the rest of Australia out of
the hands of the British but to begin
the Dutch were fine with it because the
British initially conceded half of
Australia to them if they ever wanted it
well it wasn't long in Europe until the
French Revolutionary in Napoleonic Wars
changed the balance of power on the
continent the French did send some ships
to investigate potential sites for
settlement but the British were quick to
build small settlements anywhere a
valley that the French had shown
interest in France's previous aggression
in the Britain wouldn't allow them to
colonize Australia without a war the
Dutch had lost a lot of prestige and
some overseas territories to Britain and
were just happy to get Indonesia back
Spain and Portugal were bankrupt and
largely on the decline later on the
newly founded Germany would go sniffing
around the area but the fear of German
Colonial expansion in the region was one
of the main drivers of Australian
unification at which point no other
country would ever get a look in and
Australia would be shaped by the British
until its independence in the 20th
century I hope you enjoyed this episode
with a special thanks to my patrons
James bisonet Kelly moneymaker kosher
wolf cartwitska Alex Schwinn and image
Jerry lambdin Rodney Martin AF Firefly
Marcus arsner why in hockey Spencer
Lightfoot Marvin Castle Captain said
okamun Yoon Winston K would miss izzat
boogly Wiggly Maggie pascowski the
macquapo Gustav Swan calling Dr Howard
Dr Fine Dr Howard Coppertone shuwenin
spinning three plates words about books
podcast Jim Stromberg words about books
podcast and Charles the first